qu'est ce que vous voulez savoir quel
est le doubs qui vous moquerez plus mais
bien en dixième position c'est guy lux
et léon zitrone apparemment isabelle a
voté après 9e c'est pascal bataille et
laurent fontaine en huitième position
sabrina panne explique pascal bataille
et laurent fontaine y'a que la vérité
qui compte regarder nord c'était ça va
c'est parti il était d'ailleurs c'est
christophe dechavanne ils sont en train
de taper bataille et fontaine
ils étaient six il était donc combien ça
coûte
voilà sur l'autre côté du plateau où se
tient une personne qui a quelque chose à
vous dire là comme ça pardon la première
s'appelle mal si on vous dit que cette
gêne personne en face de vous s'appelle
facile il ya serrières nom n'était pas
la même classe au cm2 j'aimerais savoir
si tu serais d'accord pour qu'on essaie
de se connaître un peu mieux je sais pas
si tu te souviens on s'est revu en fin
de sixième à l'occasion de
l'anniversaire de lola et
vous souvenez de la wii la wii merci non
au huitième position le doubs qui manque
le plus c'est kad merad et olivier
baroux
voilà l undi en septième position alors
c'est pas vraiment un duo mai gad
elmaleh jamel debbouze en anglais maison
on vit si quelqu'un connait bien de
javel 2012 maintenant qu'ils se taisent
à tout jamais caroline peut-être pouvait
pas y adhérer
on reconnaît ici moi je n'ose vous savez
plus mature dans des films comme la
fureur du dragon ou encore dans d autres
films ou strappé des petites bayonnais
qui m'avait rien dit bonjour y moi c'est
katia vous avez déjà pu apercevoir la
place clichy
michel comment s'appelle alors cette
magnifique machine très compliqué de la
part de la partie lui la barre de fer
coureurs avoir dû faire tourner la page
de faire des jeux
l'appareil multifonction de services
mystique et gad elmaleh rapport aussi
cette position c'est charly et lulu qui
vous paraît en cinquième position
patrice carmouze et christophe
dechavanne bon beaucoup en quatrième
position c'est alexandra lamy et jean
dujardin et vous nous donnez moi des jo
qui vous manque le plus en troisième
position c'est thierry roland et jean
michel larqué
regardez petit extrait mythique lille
qui remplacé par lee s'est pas trop
compliqué oui puisque le 13 à remplacer
le 18 non le 10 est toujours là alors il
va falloir être perspicace et tout voir
qui est sorti lié là alors il ya de
liens est incertain
grand appartement mais d'autant que y'a
rien qui ressemble plus à un coréen
qu'un autre coréen en deuxième position
le duo qui vous manque le plus c'est
antoine de caunes et josé garcia en
deuxième position et à votre avis en
première position de l'est je crois
qu'elle est le duo qui manque le plus
avec la mélodie morosi non il faut quoi
nous nam et sera vendu aux états qu on a
beaucoup mon ami voilà au nôtre tic et
tac merci de vos réponses
mammare 13 9 ou omar omar et fred
le duo qui vous manque le plus omar et
fred petit extrait bien sûr salué un
très bon jour amis me booste attaque à
la guitare à hugo démarre à la salle
vallier l'habitat faire coucou
d'affaires tard et je la vois les séries
es et moi y'a rien il ya un vrai duo qui
nous manque aussi
c'est jean luc lemoine vraiment on a ce
qu'on a je crois que je suis décédé mais
on a juste un extrait mois jean luc
lemoine et moi on avait fait un duo à
l'époque et il fait partie du duo qui
vous manque le moins est très très loin
enfin vous manque pas du tout je ne sais
pas du tout quel extrait regarder
[Musique]
la tour eiffel sont en tête et
l'ascenseur
[Applaudissements]